uh very good morning to you it is more
than a year since the first lockdown and
even
longer since the coronavirus first hit
the uk
but research suggests that nearly half
of people
are still unable to correctly identify
covid19 symptoms
the study published in the bmj examines
the test and trace system
also finding low rates of people
requesting tests and sticking to
self-isolation rules
let's talk to our correspondent ashley
hurunag who's in the newsroom for us
this morning i mean
12 months in ashley this is really
surprising
it really is you might think by now we
are over a year into this pandemic and
people surely would be aware of those
symptoms that continuous cough the high
temperature
the loss of taste and smell but this
study proves that
or shows rather that not many people do
know in fact what these symptoms are
neither are they adhering to the lock
down restrictions or adhering to the
self-isolation restrictions
let's take a look at some of the data
behind this what we have seen is just 18
of those with symptoms said they had
requested a test while only
43 people a percent of people with
symptoms in the previous seven days kept
to full self-isolation the data also
showed us
that only 52 percent of people could
identify
the main symptoms of covid19 those
those less likely to adhere to the rules
we know are young people from this study
but also key workers as well it's not
just a small sample either either they
have tested or
questioned 54 000 people who have taken
part in this study
and it's not just a study done by a
random organization king's college
london public health england have looked
into this data
the authors of it say that if we're
going to tackle this problem there needs
to be better messaging
clearer messaging but we are almost
after a year into this pandemic and
there has been so many government
campaigns so many
public figures fronting those campaigns
and it really comes down to the crux
of this could undermine the test and
trace system entirely which we know is
incredibly expensive
37 billion pounds that is costing us but
also we are
approaching the the opening up of the
country even further
okay ashley thank you well the labour
leader sakia stamina says he believes
the british people
won't want vaccine passports if the
virus is brought properly under control
the government's considering a passport
scheme for pubs and venues like sports
events
and music festivals well our political
correspondent kate mccann
is here interesting that this comment
comes off the back of what we heard from
spain yesterday saying they're getting
digital passports ready
in june why does sakia think this is
such a bad idea
well he says there will be a british
sense that actually it's not the right
thing to do
and in that interview in the telegraph
he said my instinct is that as the
vaccine is rolled out as the number of
hospital admissions and deaths go down
there will be a british sense that we
don't actually want to go down this road
and i think really what he's saying is
that the government is aiming to
vaccinate all adults by
around summertime the end of june and at
that point that's when realistically you
could introduce this kind of passport
but actually if everybody's vaccinated
why would we need it now we've seen
something like this already in israel
people have to flash their
phones to get into bars and restaurants
but it's really controversial too and
there are big questions about civil
liberties
the next stage of this though is whether
or not employers might ask their staff
to get vaccinated in order to come back
to work
and actually i was chatting to a
business in london pimlico plumbers just
the other day about this because it's
something they have decided to do
good afternoon thank you for calling
pimlico you're through to louis how can
i help
you could be forgiven for thinking this
footage was shot before the pandemic hit
but staff at this busy call center in
london have managed to carry on almost
as normal throughout the last
year no problem at all that's certainly
something we can help you with madam
pimlico plumbers have spent thousands to
make this happen testing staff and
visitors on site regularly
now they're going one step further and
insisting all employees have the covered
vaccine
for our staff it wasn't an issue you
know our staff was you know we're going
to get vaccinated out of people look not
upon we want to be safe we want to be
ready we
you know we talk to our engineers you're
going into people's houses it's very
important
vaccinations nobody's putting a pill
against it that everybody are for it
we're not going to hide the fact here
that anybody who now comes onto pimlico
as an engineer if you haven't had the
vaccination then you might be coming on
board with us
getting staff back to work is going to
be one of the biggest questions
employers face over the coming months
now you can spend a lot of money on
glass screens and
cover testing or you can insist that
your employees
have the covered vaccine but doing that
is going to create some huge
moral and ethical questions
ministers are discussing the use of
vaccine passports to get into pubs and
restaurants like this system already in
place in jerusalem but there is strong
opposition
making the job compulsory for staff at
work would be an even bigger
step i i think there are some quite
troubling ethical questions here because
we're getting into a situation where
people will have to
use their health status as
quite literally their passport into
ordinary social activities
now i can understand the the stated aims
of this but it does give rise to
potential discrimination
it also gives rise to a potential to
track society people who can
and people who can't be vaccinated and
for employment unions
this so-called jabs for jobs policy is
not the answer
firstly we agree vaccines are very
important and we encourage all our
members in the public to get vaccinated
but we're very very clear you know this
this should be
persuasion of people education of people
not enforcement am i really opposed to
enforcement
whatever employers do there will be a
trade-off insisting on vaccines could
put businesses in legal hot water and
spark a civil liberties backlash
but without proof of immunity social
distancing masks and other measures are
here to stay
and all of those have costs which we
will all have to bear
kate mccann sky news
let's talk to the minister for
apprenticeships and skills
jillian keegan good to see you this
morning look testing traces has cost
what 37 billion pounds so far there's
been criticism of it
throughout and now these figures showing
only 18
of people who have symptoms or even
bothering to
to get a test i mean the system just
isn't working at all
is it well i don't i don't think you can
say that i mean 9.6 million people
have actually been traced and we're
doing millions and millions of tests a
day
we're collecting a lot of data from
those tests as well uh 6.4 million have
been contact traced as well
and yeah i mean you know is the system
perfect no it's not because it relies
obviously on people doing the right
thing it relies on people getting a test
and it relies on people uh obviously
isolating if they're
they're positive so it's not perfect
system but it's certainly a very
effective system and you know there's a
lot of people who have
um you know taken tests now and uh
continue to take tests every day
including
um school school children and um those
going to college and teachers etc
now taking a couple of tests a week yeah
but we are in this situation as well
where people are not isolating
in the right way now some people may
just not want to
we sort of all understand the
frustration if you like but there is a
definite argument as well to say some
people just financially
can't afford to isolate do we need to
start looking at uh
paying people to isolate to provide some
sort of financial support to do it
well there is some financial support to
isolate which is 500 pounds
for the period now obviously you could
talk about whether that's enough or not
but there is a payment
there uh to support those who who
isolate
it you know of course it's a difficult
you know we've been at this for over a
year now
uh you know people have had to isolate
possibly several times
i mean i've only done it myself once but
sometimes you know you will have done it
several times and it
it can be a pain but you know it is
important we are all in this together
you know we are vaccinating our way out
of this uh
really really successfully but we have
to be cautious and we have to still
follow these guidelines so you know get
a test if you have any symptoms
get a test if you've been asked to by
your employer and you know
isolate if you if you are if you're
testing positive
you must isolate it really is important
it's important for everybody
all the people that we all care about
it's important that you do so
and this might be so you forgive me but
you say get a test if asked to
buy your employer we just saw that
report about pimlico plumbers
do you then support the right of an
employer to say you can only work if
you've had a vaccine we'll only
implore you if i have if you have a
vaccine is is is that a move you you
think is sensible
well there's um some well there's pros
and cons obviously to this
approach and it is quite complex as your
report outlined
um and we will be getting some um
some reports on this something that
they're looking at it at the moment on i
think the fifth of april it's due back
um to michael go for him to look at the
pros and cons of this i mean obviously
individual businesses
will make their their individual um
decisions as well but more broadly
um there'll be some more information
coming in april on on what we should do
about that based on the pros and cons i
mean we can all see
aspects of why that would be a good idea
but we can also see the difficulties as
well so the
the analysis and looking at the the
benefits versus the uh
consequences they'll uh we'll receive on
the fifth of april
uh can i ask you about the the race
report because um
yesterday obviously we were talking to
the minister and he hadn't actually seen
it in full because it hadn't been
uh fully published uh it has now um
the shadow secretary of state for women
and equalities has said
the government must urgently explain how
they came to publish
content we know it's independent but
published content
which glorifies the slave trade and
immediately dissociate themselves
from these remarks well it doesn't
glorify the
the slave trade it is an independent
report and obviously
we have the report as of 11 a.m
yesterday and we'll obviously be looking
at it's 285 pages
um i would suggest that the most
important thing that your
your viewers get is to actually read the
report and not the reports of the report
but if you uh look at what you know it
did recognize the inhumanity of slavery
it did recommend uh make many
recommendations about how we educate and
teach young people about
slavery i mean there are 10
commissioners here
um who have an awful lot of experience i
was very impressed i don't really know
the
the people but when you look at the the
the the commissioners and
you know the experiences they have i
think it's very important not to dismiss
them because they have
gone to a lot of time a lot of effort
collected a lot of evidence spoken to a
lot of people
and you know this report is less than 24
hours old
so i suggest we all report read it and
and read it carefully because
what it tries to do is get to some
implementable actions
and i've looked at the 24
recommendations some of them are in my
own area for apprenticeships as well
and i think that's the most important
thing to look and see
what policies we can do to alter
disparate
disparities in this country you know we
we definitely have to level up and we
have to level up across the country
and we have to make sure we remove
barriers to people um who
suffer from some disparities and um
inequality in the country uh talking
about uh problems in society
we know the government is now launching
this review into the the situation in
schools
um this alarming number of people have
come forward
sort of saying that they they have
either been subject to or witnessed
some sort of sexual abuse in schools i
mean this is a
dreadful situation just how robust is
this investigation going to be
minister no i think she's gone
there you go well that's uh technology
for you but not to worry we still got
some really interesting points didn't we
adam particularly about the the test and
trace system
what do you think though i'd love to
know your thoughts on uh
what you actually think about the number
of people who do not understand what the
covid symptoms are
only 52 say they do after 12 months
of living with this that's guys steve
and it'd be good to hear from you
now just after half past i'm going to be
talking to the welsh first minister mark
drakeford as the country sets out
new dates in its way out of lockdown
should the government be doing more to
help the travel sector get back on its
feet we'll be getting the thoughts of
the heathrow chief executive john
holland k
at 20 past eight and at 9 40 i'll be
talking about a new cat rehoming service
responsible for finding a record
twenty thousand felines a home over the
last year
now four people including a child have
been killed in a shooting in california
police in the city of orange a suburb of
los angeles say shots were still being
fired as they arrived at a
two-story business complex on lincoln
avenue a fifth person was injured and
the police shot and wounded the suspect
both are now in hospital authorities say
there's no further threat to the public
at this time but this is the third
deadly mass shooting in the united
states over the past two weeks
well in a tweet the governor of
california gavin newsom said
horrifying and heartbreaking our hearts
are with the families impacted by this
terrible tragedy tonight
police searching for the missing student
richard
okoragai conducting searches in essex
the metropolitan police have released
some cctv footage of the 19 year old in
loudoun in the early hours
of tuesday the 23rd of march he was seen
leaving his home
on labrad grove in west london the
evening before
the new newly released images show him
walking alone on smart's lane towards
epping forest
at 12 39
government sources have told sky news
the flagship u.n climate change summit
due to be hosted by the uk
may have to be delayed or radically
altered because of the pandemic
number 10 says the prime minister is
determined that the cop
26 summit is held face to face however
the pandemic's development in parts of
the world
have concerned some in government who've
said there are currently
too many uncertainties
the jury in the trial of derek chauvin
the former police officer accused of
murdering
george floyd in minneapolis has been
shown footage from cameras worn by the
four
officers who arrested mr floyd in may
last year
it shows mr floyd begging officers not
to shoot him after he was stopped for
allegedly trying to use a fake twenty
dollar note
this report from our u.s correspondent
greg milam does contain scenes
that you may find distressing
stay in the car let me see your other
hand i'm sorry let me see your other
hand
please both hands what ended with george
floyd's death began like this
recorded on body cameras police approach
him in his car
please man i'm not going to shoot you
step on face away
man
it was as he was led to the police car
that it turned into a struggle
shown to the jury for the first time
more body camera footage
not from officer derek shoving visible
here in the bottom right of the screen
we all know what happened next
watching it all again was clearly
emotional for this witness
he confronted officer chauvin once it
was all over
it is the first time we've heard derek
chauvin's explanation
why did you feel the need to talk to mr
chavin
because what i watched was wrong
and did you feel it was important to
tell him that
yes ma'am earlier we'd seen images of
george floyd inside the shop where
he'd appeared under the influence and
paid with a counterfeit banknote
the cashier said he now regretted
raising the alarm
we saw you standing there with your
hands on your head for a while correct
great what was going through your mind
during that time period
uh disbelief thank you
okay why guilt um if i would have just
not taken the bill this could have been
avoided
the story of that day is what this trial
is all about 10 months on where it all
happened
is now a shrine as america relives
the last moments of george floyd's life
greg milam sky news minneapolis
environmentalists are warning that new
plans to drill for oil in namibia
risk damaging one of the world's most
ecologically important landscapes
northern namibia is known for its
extraordinarily rich habitat for
wildlife
home to some of the rarest and most
precious creatures on earth
it's also the start of the akkavango
delta a sprawling world heritage site
crucial for sustaining
one of the most diverse ecosystems in
the world
but some are now worried that could all
be at risk that's because
a canadian oil company has purchased the
exploration rights to
vast sways of both namibia and botswana
in an area bordering the delta they've
started drilling
and the company says they're confident
of finding billions of barrels of oil
if they're right many fear the area
could be
changed forever with drill sites cutting
right across crucial migration routes
for the largest population of wild
elephants left in the world
from northern namibia our special
correspondent alex crawford
reports namibia is a land of dramatic
contrasts
the namib desert from which it gets its
name is known as the oldest desert in
the world in the northeast of the
country is the kavango caprivi strip
a stark contrast because of its humid
subtropical climate which makes it home
to abundant wildlife
now many living across this huge stretch
of land fear the delicate natural
balance
could all be at risk
the marwano family live in the shadow of
a massive exploratory oil drill
it's in what used to be their backyard
land they say was given by village
elders
and was once filled with crops and
livestock
andreas moana took us through his small
field of maze to show us what's there
now
i'm powerless he told us i cannot do
anything
[Music]
our drone pictures show how close his
family huts are to the well now being
drilled to discover if there's oil
beneath
namibia is one of the hottest emerging
areas for oil
and gas exploration a canadian company
called recon africa believes
there's one of the world's biggest oil
fields hiding below
we expect to confirm the existence of a
working hydrocarbon system
the sky's the limit for this company
when we do that
but andreas and his family are poor
they've hardly any money for food
never mind fighting any legal battle
yeah can't afford a lawyer he says who
will help me stand up against this oil
company
his family like so many around here live
simply
and community leaders believe poverty
has made them invisible
my feeling to them they are not
considered as human being
because their human right is not
considered
yeah that is why they are treating them
like
they are not a human being
hundreds of kilometers away it's a very
different world but andreas's concerns
are shared
you heard those elephants just in here
recon africa's oil
exploration licenses cover thousands of
square kilometers in northeast namibia
and thousands in botswana and cut across
the migration routes of the largest
remaining herd of savannah elephants
they're shy animals especially sensitive
to sound and vibration
and already at risk from shrinking
territory and poachers
the prospecting also borders the kavango
river
teeming with wildlife and a crucial
source of water in namibia
the river discharges into the okavango
delta considered one of africa's most
valuable ecosystems
this is what you could call the start of
the occupancy delta and these waters are
a
lifeblood for tens of thousands of
people
countless wild animals and a huge amount
of vegetation
it is a lifeline to a desert delta and
if
anything should happen to these waters
it will have a catastrophic impact
on multiple countries it's
up to us to predict it and if we don't
it'll be good
paint the water you'll take all the
wildlife
any intervention of man in this area
will change its wildness
in any form and we'll bring more people
we'll bring more traffic we'll bring
more pollution we'll bring more noise
and so the wildlife will be diminished
and the beauty
and pure nature that's here will be
harmed
in some way up north the drill site cuts
a dramatic scar in the midst of acres
and acres of bush
there is substantial poverty in the
kevanga basin where the site is
we met the area's traditional headsman
who told us the profits from any oil
discovery would provide
jobs and only the privilege see it
otherwise
you educated people who already have
comfortable lives
you want to restrict development here
that means we
will stay poor and probably die poor
the oil company insists it's carried out
environmental impact assessments
and they're committed to protecting both
the physical environment
and the people of the kavanga region and
they insist they don't intend to do any
fracking
which environmentalists blame for
contaminating groundwater
while the namibian government emphasizes
oil has yet to be discovered
our filming at the site soon attracted
the attention of the workers
but they were reluctant to answer any
difficult questions
this is andreas he actually
lives on this land and and he feels that
you've camped illegally on his
i'll get your information to the right
person okay would you like to say
anything to him
for andreas and the other villagers
around here there seems little recourse
since this interaction recon africa has
told us they're trying to address his
concerns
but there's still growing anxiety about
villagers land rights
and their ability to farm and what any
oil discovery would do to one of the
most beautiful
and unspoiled places left in the world
alex crawford sky news namibia
well this is sky news breakfast let's
have a look at the weather for you now
with isabel and we've had a lovely few
days haven't we is that all over now
well not in the there will still be some
sunshine stephen for a few days it's
just there's going to be much cooler
weather coming in on a northeasterly
breeze so there'll be some frost around
as well
and then my word a major change by late
easter sunday and monday so let's take a
look at the detail
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
well over the last few days whilst it's
been pretty good elsewhere the north of
scotland has been plagued by rain but
that's now moved away and that frontal
system has weakened across central areas
with a cloud breaking today
today to get some sunny spells but it's
definitely feeling cooler
with the winds quite blustery actually
from the northeast or east rather gusty
winds the cloud hopefully thinning and
breaking quite well though through this
morning
and then there should be some bright or
sunny weather for many
vast improvement in the north though a
lovely day across northern scotland
mostly cooler but uh in the scotland in
scotland in the north feeling probably a
little more pleasant than recent days in
the southwest still up to about 18 to 20
celsius but that's it really
tonight there'll be some frost across
western areas under clear skies the
northeast will be cloudier
and as we start the easter weekend
fairly promising big changes later
though more details later
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
isabel thank you still to come for you
this morning i'm going to be talking to
the welsh first minister mark drakeford
who's set to announce more measures for
easing lockdown restrictions
later on today
[Music]
they have breached the road there is a
lot of
gas being fired all around us
[Music]
india's fatality rate is less than two
percent one of the lowest in the world
the concern here is that the public
health care system is
inadequate
[Music]
it is an absolute carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for prime minister
modi's decisive degree
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
the roads have been inundated the only
way out
is to get people by boat
what is shared that over 200 people
might have died because of these
landslides
[Music]
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today
it's absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of
northeast delhi where there's been
clashes
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now nearly four million clinically
extremely vulnerable people in england
and wales will no longer have to shield
from today with many spending
more than a year without leaving their
homes or meeting others
but this change of advice won't
necessarily lead to an immediate change
in lifestyle as some
remain nervous about the virus ali
falter skew reports
it's been a year spent behind closed
doors up and down the country
we've been inside at home locked down
and isolated and no one more so than the
millions who've been shielding
so although i have my own annex here
i've actually spent a lot of this last
year
in my grandparents side of the house
like chloe who has muscular dystrophy
from today like 3.7 million others who
are clinically extremely vulnerable
she won't have to shield anymore i just
feel like i woke up on christmas day
it's that one day of the year where you
really just enjoy
being with friends and family and that
is exactly what it feels like
and i'm going to enjoy that for a few
days i'm going to enjoy this moment in
this bubble
the advice is still to minimize social
contact and work from home where
possible
but for kidney recipient matt heming
also on the shielding list
the prospect of going back to work as a
bus driver is worrying
i suppose just like i don't really
understand why
like it ends overnight i feel it should
be more
more kind of drawn out you know um
more precautions like let go slower i
don't you have a date for the second
second vaccine um
and my my consultant as advised me to uh
not return to work until at least three
weeks after
my second my second dose so what would
your advice be to people
who are shielding and don't quite feel
ready to go back to work yet
i think the first thing to say is it
doesn't need to change immediately
so some people might have been working
from home and that might be the best
thing for them to keep doing
employers should be making adjustments
and taking into account that this is a
difficult situation for someone who
might not have been in the workplace for
a long time but we know that there are
options and those adjustments can be
made safely
the people i've spoken to who've been
shielding were
genuinely frustrated particularly at the
start of the pandemic with the clarity
of message coming out of government and
how well informed they were being kept
that
i'm told has improved but as the whole
country very slowly
comes out of lockdown there are still
many who do not feel
safe coming out of isolation it is hard
not to see the moment the most
vulnerable are allowed out of their
homes as something positive
but restoring freedoms doesn't
necessarily mean confidence
in the world outside
ali sky news
now the first minister of wales will set
out more measures to ease lockdown
restrictions later on today so let's
have a look at some of the key dates for
you in 11 days
travel between wales and the rest of the
uk is expected to resume
on the same day all school pupils will
be able to return to face-to-face
teaching
the universities well it's going to be a
mixture of face-to-face and online
learning
outdoor pubs cafes and restaurants could
reopen from the 26
if infection rates remain low while gyms
leisure centers and fitness facilities
may be able to open from the 10th of may
well let's talk to the first minister of
wales mark drakeford good to see you
this morning
how confident are you in these steps
that you're putting forward
we have a good level of confidence that
we will be able to achieve
all of those dates the level of
coronavirus in wales is the lowest in
the
united kingdom and the rates of
vaccination are the highest
and all of that means that the virus at
the moment is in a relatively benign
position
we have to sustain that we have to go on
working hard
to make sure that we don't lose the
ground that we've gained
provided we can do that then there are
now dates from here
into the month of may where freedoms can
be restored
businesses can reopen and we can take
advantage
of the time of year in which outdoor
activities in particular
are easier to resume are you are you
slightly wary
in the fact that over the past 12 months
you've er
at previous points eased things sort of
quite considerably and then
you know had to enter sort of full
lockdowns quite quickly afterwards
well we absolutely want to avoid that in
the future if we possibly can
but you're right to stay the virus
hasn't gone
away and if we act as though it had as
though coronavirus had simply
disappeared from wales
then the risk will be that we'll see a
further upsurge in it and we'll be back
having to take measures
of the thought that we see being taken
in france and other european countries
today so that's why here in wales we
will go on
lifting restrictions step by step
carefully cautiously monitoring the
impact of what we do at every point
and provided we are certain that the
public health position remains
as positive as it is today then we will
be able to do all the things that we are
setting out today
how driven are you by what's coming out
of westminster
and the plans for england i mean are you
trying to keep in step
with westminster have you had a lot of
communication with the prime minister
uh we we've got a better level of
communication with the
uk government than we did earlier in the
year we have a
weekly meeting with michael gove as the
minister in charge of the cabinet office
had the latest one
uh yesterday evening what happens in
england is important to us in wales our
border is long and very porous
but we make the decisions that lie uh
to our responsibilities and we make them
in the circumstances we face in wales
but to give you an example
if travel restrictions in england are
lifted on the 12th of april
then we will lift restrictions so the
people can travel across the border
how confident are you that this is going
to be
a a one-way street out of lockdown
i mean admittedly the prime minister has
added plenty of caveats as we move down
the step process in england but there
has been this sort of overwhelming urge
to to make this
the very last lockdown are you confident
that can be the case
well of course we want it to be a
one-way street that's our aim that's why
we do things in the way
we do but i don't think anybody doing
the job that i do
could say to people in wales you know
with complete honesty
that that is bound to be the case if we
don't go on doing the things that have
kept us safe if we don't go on
observing social distancing treating
each other one another with respect
wearing masks in public places
all those things that really matter if
people get the message that because
we're lifting things
coronavirus is over the risk will be the
coronavirus comes back
at us once again so we want it to be a
one-way street we're working as hard as
we can to make
it that way everybody still needs to
play their part to make sure that that
is what happens
how much support have you got in place
for those people shielding four million
people
extremely clinically vulnerable in
england and wales no longer have to
shield
from today i'm not sure how many of
those are actually in wales but clearly
we know there is a
a lot of apprehension for people after
12 months of being indoors of
of actually coming back into society now
have you got things in place
to to help them reintegrate in a in a
confident and safe manner
we've got about 130 000 people
on the shielding this year in wales and
they will have had a letter from our
chief medical
officer uh giving them further advice
that as from today
they are able to do more in their own
lives than we would have advised them
previously
it is advice i absolutely understand
that there will be some people who have
been shielding
will not want to take advantage of the
fact so we now believe it's safe for
them to do more things
and the letter does set out the support
that's available for people
in wales through our local authorities
and through the health service
of course we want to see freedoms
restored to people even those who are
clinically vulnerable
but we want to do it in a way that gives
them confidence
that they can do it safely and at a pace
that suits them
first minister good to talk to you this
morning thank you
thank you now the labour leader sakia
stamina
said he wants to lower the bar for when
police officers investigate
anti-social behavior and give tougher
sentences
of up to two years in jail for criminals
who assault
key workers now let's talk to labour's
shadow home secretary nick thomas
simmons
who joins us now i mean determined to to
get tough on these people
it would say it would seem well look i i
think
in terms of anti-social behavior kia
is absolutely right because we have a
system
where people's lives are frankly being
made hell by low-level
anti-social behavior that isn't
necessarily
uh considered a crime and then you have
people
who are living their lives with this
going on
they need to be in a position as kia has
set out to be able to actually have the
rights that
other victims do to be able to go to a
senior police officer for example
and try to get the decisions in their
case reviewed so it's recognizing
the impact on quality of life that that
is having and with regard to your second
point with regard to
sentences for emergency services
workers that's something labor has been
arguing for a number of years my
colleagues holly lynch and chris bryant
tried to persuade the government three
years ago that there should be that
two-year sentence
uh for assaults on emergency service
workers the government seems now finally
to want to introduce that
but they need to go wider we need to we
need as well to recognize the abuse that
for example
shop workers have suffered throughout
the pandemic and put those sentences in
there as well but alongside that
we will always tackle the causes of
crime as well and we know
that preventative services including for
example things like youth clubs have
been so badly cut over the past 11 years
okay let's talk about covert can we
because sakia star was come out with
this comment that
that coveted passports are sort of not
within the nature
of the british people it sounds a little
bit strange
to come out with that at a time when you
know that i mean the idea certainly is
and right across europe of course that
the idea of
of covet passports could help businesses
reopen communities reopen
and keep people safe no i mean i've had
these discussions
over a period of time with here and and
let me just explain precisely what he
was saying
firstly internationally it's i think
inevitable the prime minister has said
that the use of
uh you know vaccine passports vaccine
certificates there's a precedent for it
with things like
yellow fever internationally to open up
international travel
in due course is something that the
government should be getting ahead of
domestically it is a far more
complicated picture
there are huge ethical legal and moral
considerations that we have to look at
and what kia was saying yesterday is
let's focus absolutely focus on the
rollout of
the vaccine let's do that but if we get
to a stage where the vaccine
has been rolled out and indeed the
restrictions
have been eased we're not we're not at
that position yet i should hasten to add
but if we get to that position what kia
was saying is
that he thinks in that situation the
instincts of the british people
would be against the domestic passport
but it is a complex issue with no simple
answers
it just seems a little bit strange
coming from a labour leader from
you know a party that not that many
years ago was talking about identity
cards
well the idea of id cards is you know 14
15 years ago now and the world has
changed very significantly
since then and we have this pandemic and
we've got to look at
what are the immediate priorities and
what we need to do and as of today
yes absolutely the government should be
getting ahead of the situation with
international vaccine passports but
domestically the priority has to be
about the rollout of the vaccine and by
the way
we're talking about uh borders and
international vaccine passports the
greatest
threat to the efficacy of our vaccines
could potentially come
from a variant of the virus from abroad
and i think people will be astonished to
learn that
only one percent of arrivals in the uk
at the moment is subject to a
hotel quarantine the government's focus
should actually be on a more
comprehensive
hotel quarantine to protect our vaccine
role and to protect
the sacrifice of the british people over
the past 12 months
okay we're gonna have to leave it there
nick thomas simmons good to talk to you
thank you
well still to come on sky news breakfast
we're going to be joined
by the chief executive of the nspcc as a
helpline goes live today
offering support to victims of sexual
abuse
in schools
[Music]
[Music]
i came across a charity based in wales
called team unlimited and
they do all the designs for these arms
um
i saw a youtube video of a child
receiving one and
and pretty quickly the the two thoughts
kind of came together we
have a student that would benefit we
have the 3d printers in the department
uh so i got in touch with with team
unlimited they modified the design
so it would um kind of be a suitable
size for for
for lewis emailed the files over um
printed it over the christmas holidays
and uh
and put it together and we trialled it
just last week for the first time and uh
it's uh it's brilliant it's working
working really well
the charity uh puts together kits that
you can purchase
to uh to put it together so the kit i
think cost about 10
15 pounds and the material was about 15
pounds so
all in the most remarkable thing
i think is the printers behind me cost
about 250 pounds
so for 300 pounds you could go from
nothing to a to a completed arm which
which is a remarkable uh it's remarkable
technology really
yeah it might be something we re revisit
every year or so
the charity are pretty good at adapting
their designs uh
to fit so you take measurements off we
took measurements off lewis's right hand
uh to ensure that the left would match
so as his right
arm grows we can retake those
measurements and uh
and reprint and yeah keep doing it for
a couple of years i'd imagine
for the early risers as we examine the
story beyond the headline
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky
news entertainment podcast but wherever
you are
welcome to the safety ridge podcast for
the ones who want to know more welcome
to the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news story
cast
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know that if we make
small changes to our lives
we can reduce air pollution by loads but
how much
exactly loads
a lot of cloud to begin with this
morning the remnants of yesterday's
front but so not much in the way of
precipitation and that cloud should tend
to thin and break
as we head through today with sunny
spells much improved picture
across the north of scotland where it
has been very wet in recent days
obviously temperatures held down only
around eight or nine on the east coast
but uh still warm
at least for one more day across the far
southwest of england
now i think in terms of air pollution
the levels are expected to be moderate
across the southwest but elsewhere as
that cooler
and windy weather comes in we're
expecting good air quality
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
now thousands of students have come
forward claiming they've experienced
sexual abuse at school
the government has since announced an
immediate review into the extent
and severity of the issue and a new
helpline run by the nspcc
goes live today to support potential
victims of sexual harassment and abuse
in educational settings well let's talk
to sir peter wandles
who's the chief executive of the nspcc
good to see you this morning look
i mean with with all the work that the
nspcc does
and and the phone lines things like
child line that you operate
how or where were you of this problem
before it's hit the headlines
uh we've been aware for a considerable
time through
um nspcc statistics that the issue of
peer-on-pier
sexual abuse is a significant one but i
think this is a
watershed moment in the way in which
significant numbers of young people are
now coming forward to
share openly their anxieties and their
concerns about
things which are happening to them which
are wrong and they're recognizing to be
wrong so
it's vitally important that now we
ensure
there's a safe independent
non-judgmental
space for them to go in order to
share those worries and concerns and
understand what needs to be done next
how do you tackle something which is
peer-on-pier
because i mean that that has to be
handled in the in a different way
doesn't it
well i think it's yeah it's it's vitally
important to talk through
and understand from the perspective of
the
of the victim what they're thinking and
feeling and what can best be done
it's also important to understand in
this sort of context what's going on
in the the minds of the of the of the
perpetrator and the factors and
and considerations which could be
affecting them uh
as well so um circumstances will vary
from
uh from case to case but it seems
probably clear from these
distressing and disturbing testimonies
that appearing online that you know we
do
have really serious um criminal assaults
within
um the the testimony that's being
declared on the website so
it's vital that the nspcc can help
people
get those concerns um work through and
to the right authorities so that can be
dealt with
uh effectively if that's the right thing
to be done
i mean it's so i mean this is a very
delicate
situation isn't it you you're not saying
then that you think all of these claims
necessarily need to be
sort of pursued legally there may be
other avenues of dealing with some of
this
i think they've all got to be taken
seriously because there are
young people here who are in a sense of
distress and concern
and want to see something done so we
need to talk and work through with them
what they consider has happened to them
so we can work through
um what the next steps are i mean the
government's launching
a review into this to look at the the
the scale of this and the in
the sort of intensity of the abuse which
is taking place
what sort of outcome would you like to
see to this because it would seem
on the surface at least that a lot of
this is going to be about
education re-education changing our
approach to how we talk about these
matters from
perhaps a younger age yeah absolutely so
the government focused particularly on
what's going on in schools
and it's vitally important that we are
confident that uh schools are
undertaking
consistently and effectively their
safeguarding
obligations but you're right it goes
much wider than that
and schools can play a vital part in the
education of young people to
understand what respectful and effective
relationships are and there's an
opportunity into the autumn when
relationships and sex education in
secondary schools becomes compulsory
to be confident that that's being done
really well and schools
are supported and encouraged to be as
good as the best because some of them
are doing fantastic work
in this area at the moment beyond that
yeah this is an issue for society
look there are things which all of us
can do to look up and look out for
for children and to encourage a culture
of uh
of respect so um that's yeah schools are
the focus today but
this goes very much wider yeah i was
going to say but any issues like i mean
you talk about the sex education we know
that is
very important but in some respects it
it is almost more important at an
earlier age to to talk about the respect
and
and empathy part part of how we behave
i would imagine yeah very much so and
uh i think that uh yeah
effective um respectful um relationships
um consent having confidence in
uh oneself and appreciating one another
these these are the fundamentals of what
it means to be
a decent human being and and so
the more we can encourage that and
through lessons through the way in which
we treat one another
um at home through the way in which all
of us uh
behave online all of these are creating
a kind of context
which unfortunately is
is leading to what we can see in some
instances
some really distressing and disturbing
behaviors
okay peter so peter i should say thank
you very much indeed
okay let's have a look at the weather
for you this morning uh isabel
oh yeah i mean i have to say you look
bright and beautiful today as as always
but it's not going to be as warm is it
today
no not as warm stephen and temperatures
really drop later in the easter weekend
which we'll talk about just now let's
take a look
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
so it's a brighter picture particularly
across the north today where we've had
days of really quite dismal weather so
some sunshine there
and elsewhere after a rather cloudy
morning hopefully the clouds should thin
and break to allow some bright
or sunny spells but as steven said yes
definitely cooler
uh seven or eight degrees for some
northeast coast there maybe 15 in london
the southwest doing okay though blustery
there but up to 18 to 20 celsius
southern ireland faring quite well for
temperatures as well but that's the last
of it
that warmth ebbing away and definitely
looking for some chilly nights as well
tonight there'll be a frost in western
areas under clear skies temperatures a
couple of degrees below freezing eastern
parts with the breeze and a bit more
cloud filtering in
probably holding up above freezing and
for good friday it does look as though
the northeast of scotland will be
cloudier
eastern england seeing the cloud coming
and going a little but elsewhere lovely
and fine with some sunshine just
temperatures though back to
average but i'm going to leave you with
a hint of what's to come on easter
sunday
rain and then wintry showers following
the weather sponsored by qatar airways